it's the battle of the governor's
California leader Gavin Newsom leaving
his dumpster fire of a state to make a
surprise stop at a Florida College to
attack Ron DeSantis Newsom and DeSantis
have been taking swipes at each other
for the past two years both have been
mentioned as presidential hopefuls for
2024. Gavin taking this pot shot at
DeSantis and his push for Education
rights
every single thing this guy does
he does with intention because he's a
weak guy masquerading as if he's a
strong guy so he takes on the most
vulnerable consistently and yet all of
them are just bewildered that they're
being used as a pawn in a political game
to try to reshape higher education
across this country this is a full-on
assault of higher education and for
academic freedom
and the Florida governor is going on
Blue Turf DeSantis showing up in
Michigan today
this leftist agenda the woke ideology is
a threat to our freedoms so we fight the
woke in the legislature but we also
fight the woke in the schools we fight
the woke in the bureaucracy and we fight
the woke in Corporate America our bottom
line is we do not surrender to the woke
mob but I've noticed it you know the
amazing part of all this Jesse is the
fact that you know Newsom said that the
students in Florida should feel like
pawns when the truth is
um he apparently forgot that he was
masking kids longer in school than any
other governor and yet he wants to
preach about freedoms yeah he's a weirdo
he said one thing I'm crawling out of my
skin for you it's a weird thing to say
remember when Romney said I'm severely
conservative something off about this
guy Gavin I can't put my finger on it
this is like the undercard you get up
here you get Trump and Romney and then
the undercard you get DeSantis and you
get Newsome and Newsome seems like this
maybe like a bantamweight who's just
trying to like like and and DeSantis is
just kind of sitting there like
seriously like seriously what are you
doing it looks like he's just trying to
campaign in case Joe Biden doesn't
campaign and so he's getting loose and
he's starting to feel himself and go to
these red States and kick up dust but it
doesn't really land because he says he
attacks the most vulnerable desantises
attack Disney the Fed chair the teachers
union the Biden Administration I don't
see DeSantis as a guy he's like picking
on vulnerable people I think he's a guy
that sticks up for vulnerable people
like the average guy you know what I
think is is almost a ironic Dana is the
fact that you had this stabbing of this
young woman in DC
and the Virginia attorney general who's
a republican uh is talking about the
fact that apparently the guy who stabbed
her
um is someone who's been released over
and over again so you have like
um you know a red State complaining
about the fact that when their people go
to a blue State they actually get
stabbed and murdered there that's kind
of analogous to this I mean California
is the highest homeless rate fentanyl
debts oh homicides are up who's he to
talk about what works and what does well
and not only that but think about the
electric grids in California collapsing
under because they're trying to move too
quickly on on a green transition you
have California running out of U-Hauls
because everybody wants to leave I mean
you have to I lived in San Diego for
three years we left a little reluctantly
however the 911 attacks had happened and
I had an opportunity to go back to DC
otherwise we'd probably still be in
California except maybe we would have
gotten a U-Haul as well because you have
to work really hard to get people to
want to leave there and so many people
have left Newsome keeps elevating
DeSantis as if he is the Republican
standard Bearer so it's probably a
relief to resent us for DeSantis in a
way because he keeps getting hit by
Trump from this side and he's like I'd
rather actually maybe fight with Gavin
Newsom because it does elevate him and
it gives him a chance to play his card
which is to say wait what about all the
Californians that have moved to Florida
and why are they moving here let's talk
about my economy let's talk about the
fact that my schools were open during
covid and you could go down the list so
I do Wonder though about Gavin Newsom
being a little bit clever here and hear
me out there is uh there are three
governors races in 2023 we're not really
talking about them too much except in
those States they are I'm going to get I
can remember too I'm just like Rick
Perry right now Louisiana
Mississippi and if anybody else I can't
remember the third one watch the one in
Mississippi because Gavin Newsom is
going there and I believe that the
Democrats have what they think is a
pretty good candidate in Mississippi and
that's why they're trying to make some
moves interesting well what about the
fact Jessica that neither has announced
and it appears that Gavin for all his
you know throwing his jacket over his
shoulder at the White House when when
Biden was out of the country
um he he can't announce before July if
Biden doesn't what's going on there well
he's made it perfectly clear he's not
running he's going to support President
Biden in his re-election bid I have no
reason to think that plans
have changed and that Joe Biden will not
be running for re-election but what I
was overwhelmed with watching this is
how much this is what the American
public want to see they want to see two
young Governors right 40s and 50s who
have track records to defend who have
charm different kinds of I've heard
DeSantis is charming I don't find him as
Charming as I might find Gavin Newsom
but
people are and it shows it on both sides
they don't want to nominee in their 70s
or 80s they want to see who's next
what's happening here and I think that
that is something important to be giving
the American public to say there are
young stars coming up in both of these
parties and you should pay attention to
that
um I know Dana brought this up yesterday
on the show and talked about it this
morning on America's Newsroom what
happened in Wisconsin with the Supreme
Court there and the fact that they lost
their super majority and is anyone on
the Republican side going to address
what's going on with younger voters just
the bleeding of gen Z and frankly
Millennial voters and when they talk
about education there's an important
point there for younger voters because
if the Republican position in DeSantis
goes so hard at the teachers unions
that's going to be a problem for them
and likewise nusoma has to moderate his
position on that to talk about what
might have gone wrong in public schools
but last week Governor DeSantis very
quietly signed find a permitless carry
Bill he usually does very public
signings this one was in private the NRA
lobbyist was there even 62 percent of
Republicans opposed that bill and you
look at something like what's going on
in Idaho that's first aid to restrict
Interstate travel to get abortion care
with things like that looming over the
Republican party they will not be able
to win an election
I suspect you're right that youth is
probably appealing to the electorate but
I think more appealing than youth is
authenticity not being a fraud and that
line stuck out to me as well Jesse I'm
crawling out of my skin for you right
he's not crawling out of his skin for
anyone no vulnerability that he sees out
there no vulnerable class it's a
fraudulent message he has no empathy he
is not there to fight for any little man
he'd Bud Light for example doesn't care
about Dylan Mulvaney's 365 days of
Womanhood Nike doesn't care about the
transgender movement this is all
incentive based for them it's business
for him it's playing these people for
potential votes and and with the most
fraudulent aspect of this is his record
he was he inherited the Pacific Ocean
and ruined it people are leaving
California good luck convincing the
American people where are we going to
move when we're done with Gavin Newsom
yeah but by the way isn't it a snake
that crawls out of his skin it does yes
maybe maybe Gavin Newsom is actually
making your skin crawl hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else